Ma'am, are you okay?
It didn't seem real because of what was going on around.
You know, traffic was going as normal.
Pedestrians were going by as normal.
Ma'am, are you okay?
She was distraught.
She was distant.
She was really disconnected.
I grabbed her and I grabbed her arm and I put my arm around her and I said,...
..."Do you wanna come on this side of the guardrail?"
And that was actually the first time she actually spoke to me.
She said, "Yes."
It was meant to be.
I was supposed to be there for her at that moment.
And I was.
I wanted to convey that whatever it was...
...we're gonna help you through whatever it is.
And it's not as serious as jumping onto the 198.
I felt like I did what I was supposed to do at the time.
I'm a football guy, so when you sit on a bench and the coach calls your number,...
...you gotta go in there and make a play...
...and you gotta do what the play calls for and I think that's what I did.